[Music]
Good morning. Not a single news broadcast for
weeks has
mentioned the Clearstream affair. But what exactly is
Clearstream? A
mysterious money laundering operation, the key to many
drug trafficking,
arms trafficking, globalization, and
layoffs? Our guest today
is Denis Robert, journalist, writer, artist, and
author. Ten years ago, he conducted an
investigation into Clearstream. Clearstream
is a financial clearing house
based in Luxembourg,
then unknown to the general public, whose
shady dealings he denounced.
Today, everyone in France
knows Clearstream; it has
obviously become synonymous with a state scandal. Ten
years of legal battles, 60 trials,
hundreds of bailiffs at your door, and some serious enmities
in the political world—there are still some
among your colleagues
in the press—and then a flash of lightning, and
then darkness. After ten years, on
February 3, 2011, it's still very recent:
the Court of Cassation has
definitively ruled against you and recognized
your work.  So, your job as
journalists and investigators
[Music] there's the
internet, you know, they can't do
anything against the internet, well, not yet, they can't do
anything on the internet, no, but they won't be able to,
they can make all
the laws they want, I mean, screw them, they won't succeed.
When I saw François Hollande at Le
Bourget attacking finance, and so on,
I thought it was pretty good, but I
sensed a big bluff. Besides, that's what
wins a lot of
elections because he had
Sarkozy on the banking issue, he
was pathetic. Hollande doesn't give a damn
about the issue of
tax havens, it's all talk, it was a
way to stay in power. If they
really had a strong political will
to fight against
tax havens, they had, they have all
the attitude to do it. Well, from an
economic point of view, it's a catastrophe
for the print media, that's
obvious, sales of Le Pen fell
by 16% last quarter, those of L'Obs
fell by  14 and L'Express, which has had a significant
drop in share price, is in a
catastrophic situation. Does the
fact that journalists don't present
the figures correctly, or present them in an
embellished or misleading way, imply
journalistic misconduct or a
lack of information? Of course,
your question contains the answer.
The financial press is undoubtedly the
most subservient press, beholden
to banks and
financial groups. Financial journalism—and I
might be
blunt in my statement—doesn't exist.
We can clearly see that behind it all there are
pressure groups,
press groups, and so on, and that we are
generally bombarded with indices,
stock market figures, and everything else that are
completely falsified. There's a kind
of grand lie surrounding all of this, and
I don't believe in conspiracies, I don't believe in
all that, but I know very well that
these newspapers are paid for by Arnaud,
by Pino, by the banks, and
that there are advertisers, and that there are...
All this, and that you can't displease anyone, you know?
And I saw it with Clam, it was
the absolute worst. You were bombarded with
lawsuits, and even if you win, you lose.
Newspaper publishers and journalists
are so afraid now, not
even of losing lawsuits anymore, but they're
afraid of lawsuits because of the
procedures. Obviously, there's
self-censorship and there's censorship, and that's
dramatic. The Kusac affair, to
talk about her, showed that when you
have a strong journalistic will,
you can overthrow powers. We'd like
your opinion on the
Snowden affair. I found it incredible
that France didn't grant him
asylum or justice. But here we're
in geopolitics, we're in
real politics, and we're in... well, you can't
attack the United States with impunity.
These people are playing politics, but
they're not really doing politics, so they have no
courage, they have none, and they're
selling their souls.
They're lost, they're losing,
losing every battle. There's the
internet, you know, they can't do anything
against the internet. Not yet, they can't do
anything on the internet, no, but they won't be able to do
anything. They can make all the laws
they want, I mean, screw them, they won't succeed.
[Music]
Actually, Prism is just a
specific sub-program of a
more general plan. It used to be called... it's also part of a
program we know called
Echelon. So neither the Russians nor
the Chinese want the UN to
turn into a machine for giving
good and bad
governance points and
[Music]